Chris waterers we both recently had a
chance to sit down and play some
civilization beyond Earth the rising
tide which is the expansion for beyond
Earth it's coming out this fall you
played a lot more beyond Earth than I
have Oh Kevin stuff you have haha so you
have answers for all of my questions of
course watery stuff is is big in the
rising tide you're able to have water
based city's water based civilization
and my question for you is I while
playing one of the first things you find
is that you can move a city on an entire
city like kind of a a slug going across
I see you just like fire up the outboard
motor like another usually moving the
whole thing one hex right but you can
yeah you move it across the ocean it
take it's like it's like building a
building you like all your cities
production efforts go towards moving the
city and like that's the only way to
gain territory in a water city you don't
expand via culture you have to
physically like basically paint your
cult you're like your sphere of
influence by moving your idea around and
then all of a sudden you're moving
everywhere very quickly and you know II
movement is changed and expansion has
changed and so I mean you want to move
your cities one so you can get more
strategic resources it's the only way to
get new things inside your production
sphere too so you can like claim terrain
and like block your opponents or like
get to the thing before your opponent
does you can use your city as like a
mobile battle platform even because you
know cities have huge defense and you
can bump up your city defense but yeah
some interesting interesting
possibilities yeah totally some other
possibilities that come up are in
diplomacy and there's there's this
introduction of a of a new resource as
it is in diplomatic capital and I didn't
get a lot of chance to play with that
but what I noticed is if I went and
talked to other leaders I could exchange
this diplomatic capital for favors
and I'm kind of curious if you have
anything to shed on how how like this
diplomatic capital is actually working
well any time you introduce a new
resource into civilization like gods and
Kings did with civ 5 you are like
introducing a whole new facet of the
economy so like you can build buildings
a crew diplomatic capital you can make
trade agreements that sort of pass
diplomatic capital back and forth and
for me it's the trade agreement stuff
that is really what fuels this new
diplomacy system and really what makes
it a huge like strategic consideration
because depending like every leader has
their own specific sort of diplomatic
trait and then you can focus on like
domestic traits military traits or
political traits and once you start
investing capital in those areas like
dozens of different trade agreement
possibilities open up and some of them
are like yo you and I make a trade
agreement that costs each of us
diplomatic capital but then we each get
boosts to our production or our food or
our goal something like that not gold
whatever energy then there's other ones
that are like if you make this agreement
you can like all workers are free or
your trade transports have protection
they're not just easily taken by
whatever alien or enemy and so there's
just a lot of stuff in there I mean tens
and tens of different kinds of
agreements that strategically can have a
really profound impact on how you build
your city we only got to play about 150
turns in our demo so we didn't get to
like see the impact of all of them but
just looking at that list there's some
pretty staggering implications right and
there's there's more to it as well in
terms of diplomacy because now leaders
sort of have their own personalities
their own strengths and that also plays
into the gameplay even outside of
diplomacy as far as I can tell they're
coming up on my screen they're saying
hey you we like that you're gaining some
population or hey we hate you because
because you're you don't have enough
cities and what the heck is going yeah
like text messaging you right there's
like little notifications that pop up at
the top and it's one of the ways they're
like really trying to like I don't
reinforce the fact that like
these leaders in civ beyond Earth aren't
just like randos that they made up they
have personalities they have traits they
are characters you know and so by
putting they're trying to really amp up
the amount of character that you sort of
that is in the mix because they don't
have that historical relevance of
previous sibs head and then just one
last thing I want to ask about is just
aliens are cool right yeah and we did
get to see some some some new things
because we were out at sea the thing I'm
most interested in is is Hydra coral
which so when you're at sea you don't
have you know you can move a little bit
faster your units often can can can move
more hexes in the turn of the strain of
deductions right the open ocean but
there is Hydra coral which is sort of
this floating stuff it's sort of like a
floating tentacle creature that has
coral growing on top of it and I'm kind
of wondering what's what's the deal with
Hydra Cora what am I going to be doing
with that what what's it what's it out
there doing yeah it's like it grows of
its own accord and it's it's like an
environmental feature I mean you can
destroy it and you know you can attack
it but like it will just pop up so like
the straight that you pass through fine
with your explorers in the early game
you might come back through and be like
Oh up there's a ton of coral here can't
go there crap so it's kind of a way I
think to like create that kind of
terrain restriction on the ocean and
then there's some you know you can like
let it grow it conservative as a barrier
between you and your enemies it could be
good or it could be jacking up your
exploration and you maybe want to clear
it but it's also tied into this sort of
an example of like a way they're
building out the quest system there's
this marvel quest where you like
discover this huge Hydra coral and
you're like oh this is a weird brain
Hydra coral and then you find it like
sends you to find a couple other
examples and then by doing so doing this
research you gain a buff for some
attribute or something like that so
expanding on that quest system that they
introduced and beyond Earth with some of
that stuff with these quests and hydro
portal tied into it but yeah another
weird kind of consideration to deal with
the weird wild world of
building cities and conducting
civilization on water yeah so obviously
there's a lot more to beyond Earth the
rising tide we've got a thing up on
gamespot you should go read the article
which divulges even more information
than we've talked about here and you'll
get to play this fall on PC civilization
beyond Earth the rising tide I say the
rising tide because I keep forgetting to
say the in front of it but it is there
it did a good job in order thank you so
much you got I got it you're gotta do
this baby so in the meanwhile stay tuned
the gamespot read that thing read other
stuff watch more videos will be here to
tell you all about the video games